did you see the question that they asked
Biden yesterday about musk did you see
that question oh yeah can you post it
can you put it up real quick very
interesting watch this here watch this
here
Elon Musk is a threat to U.S national
security and should the U.S and with the
tools you have investigate his joint
acquisition of Twitter with foreign
governments which include the Saudis
look how long this takes
I think that
why
he's thinking
look cooperation and or
technical
relationships with other countries
is worthy of being looked at
whether or not he is doing anything
inappropriate I'm not suggesting that
I'm suggesting that it worse worse being
looked at and uh
what a vile statement it's worth being
looked at I'm not saying he's doing
anything but we're gonna look yeah we're
gonna freaking look we're gonna keep
look also he has no idea what he's
talking about his people have been the
ones for the last two years we now know
it all those docs that were leaked that
intercept covered we know that the
government was coordinating with big
Tech to silence people it is the it is
the greatest mass violation of the first
amendment in the history of America and
I don't even know did they even cover it
on CNN I actually checked the day the
story broke it was not on CNN's front
page but you know what was uh The Oath
Keepers which is some Trump related
something the day of January 6th the the
Insurrection they spent 400 at Olive
Garden that was what that was on the
front page of CNN that's unbelievable
the day that they break these ducks
that's what we're up against they do
give free breadsticks no I mean so it
seems like it's a lot of money
but here's my question with that because
that's I mean whether you're left right
center up down purple that's not good
like that you can't look at him and be
like that's my guy and I'm not God but
why would he stop but why would he stop
but here's my point you'd rather have
Biden office at the very least than
Kamala right I mean you came from
California because if you're suggesting
let's get rid of Biden let's get him out
of there let's impeach him let's use the
whatever Amendment together
then you get Kamala no it's all bad I
don't want that it's all bad and these
people will never stop that's what's the
most disappointing but who'd you rather
have Biden or Kamala I don't think it
matters yeah it don't matter neither one
of them yeah there's a little bit
honestly like my theory my theory on
Kamala is that her speechwriters are
actually working for us because some of
the stuff that's coming out of her mouth
you know I did a sketch on values they
were where I'm tripping out because we
can't find the speech and I'm like it's
outside the writers when we walk in a
room and it's pets and everybody
throwing [ __ ] all over the place time
yeah time the passage of time but I
don't understand we had this
conversation the other day about Elon
Musk and I was like what's with this
hatred of Elon Musk I know I don't get
it and we checked his Q score right what
were the results of that Q score just
it's the media it's the politicians it's
bureaucracy but the people love Elon
Musk he's about to the exception of
Dogecoin whatever he's enabling equal
time and he is destroying one of the
pillars of speech control that was in
front of them so what all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valutamin it says future
looks bright here future looks bright
here we got them in white we got them in
Black we got them in red our black on
black sold out these are about to sell
out if you haven't ordered one yet we
had a person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks bad toward
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
[Music]